that's the question we should be asking
no it's the question of the way the
human mind is
and so when people actually operate very
often they're trying to get positional
advantage
okay that's how we operate
and it's not wrong i mean basically we
do need to worry about our relative
fitness that means that if i what's
enlightened is to make sure
that we all do something that's
cooperative okay
we're all working towards cooperative
solutions make no mistake
about that but when you look at how the
human mind actually
operates you there's two things you can
say about it
it privileges positional advantage
and short-term
gain as opposed to long-term gain we've
all learned about discounting the future
that a benefit now is going to be
more important than that same benefit
delayed in time why is it is because i
might not live that long
and so especially when you put people in
precarious situations
existentially insecure situations their
minds are going to
privilege immediate gain
and if you tell them immediate relative
gain immediate relative
gain and if you tell them they'll be
better in the long term [ __ ]
as far as what they need to do and what
their minds are telling them to do
in order to survive another day in order
to survive another day
and one of my colleagues robert frank an
economist
a well-regarded economist
wrote a book called the darwin economy
in which he makes this
very uh point he says a hundred years
from now
i hope it doesn't take that long darwin
not adam smith
will be regarded as the father of
economics and the main difference
is that economists as i've just said
they posit
the national actor homo economicos
the utility maximizer only wants to
maximize its absolute utility
not in reference to anyone else as if we
only want to be wealthy in some absolute
sense
not in comparison to anyone else well no
one works like that
the only reason you want to have a
thousand dollar suit is to look better
than someone with a 500
suit life is about relative
advantage and yet economic theory has
not framed that
that way so that's the sense in which an
appeal to enlighten self-interest
it's it's a nice aspirational message
but really it it
it it misses all of the complications
that we've just been talking about